yes we've received apologies from
councillor pete elliott and councillor
james
declarations of interest
members are requested to develop the
existence and nature of any disposable
premium interests by your other
interests not already on their register
of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdrawal
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
anonymity procedure
item three minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
on tuesday the 23rd of august
are we happy that they are a correct
record
if so is
all those in favor
that brings us now to the main item of
business meeting
before we start i would like the client
to explain the benefit members speakers
and those watching on youtube how we
will deal with
thank them chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated too
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
but the two speakers registered today
will be speaking on the second
application
they will have three minutes to put
forward their views
they'll be reminded given by the clerk
when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask to speak with
questions if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting
but they will not be allowed to
participate further from that point
the chair will then open the meeting for
questions to officers a debate by the
committee and finally determination on
the application by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll calls
finally members this meeting is being
recorded and has been shown live on
youtube
the recording will be placed on the
council's website
please note that others may choose your
properties
thank you chair
thank you move on to our first
application
uh
moving on to our first application
practice i'm going to ask the global
officers to tell us about any late
comments and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans at this site
i will allow the officers to complete
the presentation
consequently language could you please
reserve any points of questions about
the process until the end
this one
this is a proposed change of use from
the shop and house to nine bedroom home
performance occupation
at 205 to 207 sheffield road
the application site is located from
south of sheffield road and is outlined
in orange on this slide
this is the red line plan submitted by
the applicants this plan also shows the
location of secure cycle parking cycle
storage proposing the rear of the
property
that concludes the parking to the rear
however the highway is considered narrow
access on sheffield road to be
substandard
this slide shows the existing layout of
the property with the shop and retail
related storage on the ground floor and
the residential accommodation on two
stories above
the accident
shop sales are now down particularly
since covered pandemic accounting openly
including markets close by
these are the proposed drawings as you
can see the ground floor will be
converted to premiere areas including
dining and lounge and kitchen
one bedroom is proposed on ground floor
two and six two thousand and three one
thirty bedrooms are supposed in total
this slide shows the position of the
building on the edge of the area
designated designated in the local plant
is the kilimanjaro town centre
this plant also shows how close the
building is to the town centre and to
other shops which sell similar products
to the news agencies that is currently
in the building
following slides a selection of those
shows the site visit and here is a
reminder
this slide shows the shop with the
surgery on the right and the narrow
access to the road can be seen on the
left of the property
this
slide shows how narrow the access is to
the rear and as consequences of this
highways we're not supporting the
parking proposed
this slide shows sheffield road to the
west with the surgery and chemistry
foreground
parking space has shown me about
40-minute wait times which should ensure
that should residents have cars they
won't park close to the doctors and
pharmacists
this shows sheffield road to the east
again the parking spaces have 40 minute
wait times
and you can see the bus stop which
serves regular buses to number number of
local destinations the consequences is
considered that the proposal is in a
sustainable location where parking is
not required
offices are a good news but as the
proposal is limited in scale it would
not have a harmful impact on the
character and functionality of the marsh
town centre
as the services that it provides are
replicated sorry as the services that
the current shop provides are replicated
close by elsewhere it would not result
in the last of important social
infrastructure and due to its
sustainable location post account center
and bus routes the proposal would not
have a harmful impact on highway safety
or parking in the areas as searches has
recommended that the applications each
cruise
thank you chad
thank you as with no speakers for this
afternoon um
yeah good afternoon a few questions uh
please uh one of them why you show the
current layout it would have been nice
to have received that in our past
maybe compared it on the paperwork but
that's not the question but what the
main question is
do they have i mean the officers
recommended approval for this but my
concerns is
do they have any minimum standards
it's for the residents or tenants that
are likely to be living in here because
it says what the 15
[Music]
it shows the fruit of a red car
um so the uh
um layout of the building does meet the
minimum requirements um
and
the space this place the national space
standards in fact the room sizes are
probably larger than the minimum and the
number of bathrooms and separate and
wt's are
meet the requirements
um
and as far as the parking is concerned
he didn't
seem appropriate to include that type of
property
through the phones that perhaps
whether it was that same car or whether
it was another car that managed to drive
down to the rear of the property
recently the motion of the access is
only 2.2 meters wide so that's why
highways have got issues and that is a
formal kind of parking area for the hmo
yeah it's okay i just wanted to double
check whether it was the same red car or
if it was another one that's all
cancelled faster
[Music]
or office appeals or planning uh
committee
foreign development due to the impact on
parking from that
and
we're only looking at id3 which is
impact on highway safety getting a
complete incoming
really the first question is around that
what sort of weight can we put on that
uh assessment first question what way
can we put on that as a as a planning
committee because we we don't seem to
have any other policies that mark from
ibt which is impact on highway safety
which is different really so that's the
first one and then i've got concerns
about the statements on page 12
which is the highway authority
the generated traffic needs to change
but also results in demonstrable uh
material arm etc uh and as such that
refusal could be sustained that's not
really their job
highways it's our job too
and i feel like we're being
maybe being pushed a little bit with
that statement so i'm sure from there
from what i've remembered previously
from highways being
myself
that uh it's not their job it's not
highway's job to say whether the future
could be sustainable that's our job
so
some comments there
thank you
thank you
yeah thanks for the the questions
council foster that's great so yeah
first of all on the
the draft which is street design
guidance
i'll be honest that's the first time
i've seen that reference
as a
[Music]
authority
yeah the view that i was thought to
bother not was going to demonstrate harm
if it went to an appeal we want to
conduct county council highways through
supports of appeal so if they
have convinced that they
retail shop and it's a five-bedroom
property so those those cars as you can
see the access is really narrow to the
side of the property i think officers
it perhaps was more appropriate to clean
access points
[Music]
and so perhaps just an explanation for
me
i'm not sure how this works when it
comes to
working through a planning application i
thought that's the sort of thing we
could we could ask for uh an application
before we even concept that because it's
something i'd want to know but they
don't really take place not just nine
battles online
that's something that i want to consider
at this stage well then afterwards make
it condition yeah
because it's sort of it you can just
come off the shelf afterwards as long as
you've got the planning mission
thank you
two things really uh
once uh
a lot of people don't know
at any one time
[Music]
[Music]
nonsense today
just just where that white line is
and uh
in front of the entrance to the alleyway
and
they did we did discuss including that
in the application however
their red line wasn't correct for that
and so this had to start from the
beginning
again
so we
came to the conclusion that given that
highways were not happening about
cars using that access anyway
and we came to the conclusion that
probably at this stage the best solution
was to take bring this application to
use now with no parking
so
we brought it to you
and to make a decision based on home
parking
um
what so i'm sorry what was the first
question
higher regulations and that would be
covered by building
[Music]
typical car owners live in the night
roll but still is up to that
the question really is
how many people would you have to have
in a property with no parking and still
let it go through you know we'd be 25
would that will be start to be a concern
now i know when it comes to our policies
it's parking work impacts on highway
safety but there's also
the residents there and the parish
councils there aren't just talking about
that they're talking about the impact on
parking itself on how it affects other
people the arts park outside their house
i know we got to the right park outside
our house but the nearest houses
those people have cars in that property
that come to live in that time or will
end up parking outside someone else's
else's house so it will have an impact
on the residents of color marsh some
residents not all but just some but then
those residents an awful lot so at what
point would we actually consider it
that's the first question i don't need
to select the second one is what policy
would we consider in that case what
would we use to turn
this down into due to concerns on
parking but not at e3 impact on highway
surface
thank you
i can't tell you the answer to the first
part of that question
because i need to cross our highways
because we are taking the legal
advantage with regards to what would be
appropriate
and but if we were
um to use it on parking branches we've
been using scc-12 as a perception
okay
which is my provision for um
private community space storage
recycling space and vehicle and cycle
parking
i have two other questions for you and
this one
[Music]
these plans don't show any fire escape
accessories
so if they
weren't able to deliver it and the
building makes them
so what we consider standards for
something like this are we working on
any standard at all while we're working
off the that's why i asked about that
the highways one of the highways one
that you said you give limited weight
too
but in my mind it's been that one's been
designed currently to fill a gap it
looks like it is and the way it's in
draft form it looks like it was there
for that
so really what
how do we constantly
request advice how do we consider this
weight to the one from dcc
and yet this one here we've got we've
got our own sdc 12k
uh and we that it should make provision
so
it doesn't look like it makes provision
i don't sound a bit dense there it
doesn't look like it makes provision
look like it makes any provision at all
and so
since the
adoption of the new plan
we don't have parking gardens
there was parking burdens in the old
plant there isn't hard
and the county council
don't have currently have guidance on
hmo so that's where we are coming from
but all of us as planners yourselves
included are coming from
and
so
that that draft is saying
ideally three problem spaces but
the highways authority are prepared to
back up a refusal on parking so that's
where we we are with it
we and
when i just have discussed this with the
high resolution
we've had quite a lot of tuning going
about the parking and they came down on
the side saying
that they wouldn't
back the refusal based on on parking
uh so that's where we why we've come to
the conclusion that we've come to
and it is yeah it's sticky without
formal guidance adoptive
[Music]
is also that sustainable location
of where we are so we're 25 meters away
from a bus stop
we've got the local facilities in the
center so the right
i think it's quite low
in that circumstance but you know if
members of me that some parliament
should have provided do you want
substandard access and parking to the
rear is that something that numbers want
to come to part of the application
because that's that's why we're tuning
from to the profile is that we've gone
from low provision marketing then we're
trying to provide parking and now we've
ended up with the situation that was
going forward to members today
the choice is not that about through
often spaces on your
that's the real choice it's not at least
it's not whether we should align with
three or not three
but that's true
thank you
can we just go back to the street scene
where it shows you the doctor
has the doctor's surgery
that's the current layout
between that votes
how it was told
is
i would say there must be a restriction
so whether people do it
[Music]
is it possible
that the committee could defer this
application until we sought
further guidance
not from highways so i know the guidance
to give us but the actual that draft
also trying to look at that draft policy
ourselves is that possible because it's
obviously been it's been written it's
been put forward and i'm sure it's been
the
system months it's there for a reason
uh it's the policy on hands
and
is that something that's possible to
chair often
he i've been quite happy with you
because i'm quite concerned about the
parking but i'd also like some actual
physical evidence about the giant
escapes as well once people which was
council
so
if there's
[Music]
a lot of these hmos
could be being used for young people
who have found it very very difficult to
get accommodation
but we haven't got any idea of this
target
um
well it's something that's needed in the
area it may not be liked that you've
been really much but it is a necessary
thing that they have to do hispanic
accommodation
for young people
thank you
i think we all share those concerns that
we know this accommodation is required
but i think we need to get it right from
only the residents that are going in the
residence halls
[Music]
thank
you not a show of hands
i think that's your name
thank you is anyone against that
uh hmo parking and also fire regulations
[Music]
moving on to our second application
long
thank you
okay
uh yes this is the application for
direction in the detached double garage
with jingle bells and more grange don't
hold the bracket field
and we've received uh one late
representation from this field and which
deals with
all four of the applications on this
site
and
i believe that both mrs hills and the
agents are speaking today but in summary
and the following
excerpts relate to this application so
we're just going to bring phones out of
that
chat
and
we've noted various comments on the
planning applications launched by us for
more range and so you detail below the
background and reasons for the
applications may address any concerns
which are the reason
we are two couples all retired with no
interest in running a for-profit
business at more grains we're hoping to
expand a small group of rescue courses
which we presently have elsewhere and to
encourage support
and support wildlife particularly
these applications together enable us to
do this in a synthetic practical way and
to keep them more ranged very much as it
is now
and then goes on to talk about the other
applications which aren't before us
today and then with regards to the
carriage
and which is this application the
application is for a garage for more
range house which presently has none
carriage matches more grain and built
form but will be singles
single story
separate from the main lands and
buildings and has made facilities
being surrounded by high walls boundary
plants
[Music]
the two-story detached garage will be
located to the west of moorgrange decide
to show the orange on the side
wider side as a whole has been purchased
by two sets of friends who intend to
live and develop sites at home
mr and mrs menthols have applied to the
garage mrs heels required for conversion
of a
[Music]
these applications are not yet ready to
be brought to community
this slide shows the red line location
of the proposed garage as you can see it
is separate from the
house this slide shows the location of
the barn separate from the house and
close to the top of the access drive the
garage will have a footprint of 6.6 by
6.6 meters
this slide shows how large the footprint
is in relation to the existing house
these are released by the proposed plant
and elevation drawings
the building will be constructed of
stone and slate to match the host
property but its height gable width and
steep wreath pitch are advanced with the
host property and other traditional
buildings on site
morgrange is an attractive 19th century
house with sash windows a hip roof with
serbian health buildings which are
located to the north and east of the
host property
the height of the proposed garage means
the ridge will be toasted level with the
ease of the host proposed as well and
offices are approved that due to the
combination of the heights and design
particularly the steep steel pitchery
and wide gables which does not respect
that of the host swelling or existing
traditional outbuildings the proposal
does not represent the level of good
design required by the northeast culture
local fund policies ss9 lc5 elf scc-12
ignore the level of good design
encouraged by the nvp
the following slides include the
selection of the photos that were shown
this shows the house and location of the
proposed garage from halfway down the
drive the proposed garage will be
located approximately when car is at the
top to drive
the screen the trees would screen the
building from the a6105
however this photo shows that when
viewed from dewey lane to the south side
of the proposed barrage is clearly
visible it assists visibility combined
with the poor design and sighting which
has led offices to the conclusion that
the proposal does not mean the design
punch site and landscape policies
today on this application the first is
john imber the agent for the application
and the second is
who is speaking on behalf of the
applicant
as the class explains they will be
informed when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them to
paraphrase any numbers that have been
raised but remember your question should
only relate to the points which have
already been made
so we will start with this
if you'd like to take the seat
thank you the opportunity to speak this
afternoon
the officer's report makes it clear that
the proposals are not unacceptable in
principle and will not impact upon
neighbours or the safe and efficient use
of the highway network
the key question here is whether the
garage would have a sufficiently
detrimental impact upon the character
and appearance of surroundings toward
refusing the application
it is our view that it does not
the garage is to be constructed from
material flattening those the existing
dwelling
it is subservient to more grade in terms
of its scale height and sighting being
smaller lower and set back behind the
front elevation of the existing house in
accordance with policy lc5 at the local
pump
the report suggests the garage should
have a hit roof to match the house
however all of the traditional detached
outbuildings
in the house have gabled ends and the
proposed carriage maintains its approach
in our view that is a far more
appropriate response to its contact
the garage would not be prominent from
public vantage point it is set back from
doha lane and views are filtered by the
frontage hedgerow and into being
landscaping trees
distant views of the garage will be made
from dewey lake as shown in figure 4 of
the office's report
from this vantage point impact will be
significantly diminished by range and
the gauge will be viewed in the context
of existing buildings on the site
including the stone volunteers
it would also be set against the
backdrop rising ground
the garage will find no means appear
problem from julie and if figure 4 shows
the strongest case to back up the
recommendation of refusal on visual
ground then that case is not terrible
in our view the proposals would not
material impact upon public view to
decide
under such refusal on visual grounds
cannot be substantiated in this instance
thank you for your time
thank you
too are there any questions
council
thank you chair i'd just actually like
to clarify what what you said in
conjunction with what the officers just
told us um because obviously everything
we've got in the report talks about
two-story building
obviously what's just been said in what
i appreciate it absolutely the garage on
the ground floor and then in the roof
spaces left there's a given storage area
that's right
that's for a montage
yes
this
sorry relative to relative to uh
package
uh
how is that relative to
more range building i mean i guess the
height of that is
exponentially more than six meters do
you know the exact spot
you measured that this morning
if it helps the the height of the ridge
of the garage is broadly equivalent by
the ease of more drainage so the ridge
height of wardrobe will be substantially
higher
are there any first questions at this
stage
and second speak this afternoon
three minutes
[Music]
um
this
um yes i just wanted to introduce
ourselves and give a brief background to
more range because this is
some comments on the planning website
occasions and particularly about sizes
of the carriage
we're two
couples all retired and we decided a
couple of years ago to buy somewhere
that we could make our home
and where we could restore some
buildings about some kids animals
more range is ideal for us it has a high
switch needs some innovation
[Music]
but it has its own private drawing
we did notice one comment in particular
saying that the driver uses access to
another building within more range but
that's actually not possible
long range counts and the proposed
damage just at the end of their own time
they're surrounded by high walls of
angry birds and mature rooms so you
can't die
from more range probably the driver of
the image goes on to
arrange farm buildings
uh mr and mrs northball did put
so the building hopefully will impress
the national arrangements itself
[Music]
we all feel that we want to keep more
range visually very much as this is now
we don't want to start adding other
buildings which are less attractive than
we already have for the attractive
character so we thought that going down
the planet is probably the right
um
beyond that we've got no interest in
making any changes
by submitting all the applications
together as probably
but we just hope we start to restore the
voters at once rather than one
application
as i said you don't want to change your
range we just want to bring the
presentations up to a good standard
which is
nice
that's it
very well are there any questions
nope
tennessee that's fine thank you
are there any questions for officers
councillor hancock
thank you for the chair and apologize
um although obviously we are looking at
this one particular point again well
obviously that
my is is that because of the height of
the building
and its width and the steepness of the
slope of the roof
it's it's not in the center as the other
outbuildings
yeah thank you so from what you just
said really if it was scaled back then
it made me more acceptable
yeah i think the principle of the garage
on that site is or an outbuilding on
that site is acceptable it's more about
the design and
how that relates to the other buildings
and the fact that it's visible
just ask
[Music]
is
so i think
because because of the height of the
roof
because they want the two stories of the
space above
the
height of the roof is more like
the
the proportions of the house
where you've got a higher and
a steeper picture but the stupid picture
is then hit
so the
in
so
my view was you could have
a a garage with a hitch room that would
have higher through
higher second story
or
the
other outbuildings have much shallower
and green pitch
and narrower gables so
but this is kind of this is
wide gable and the seat pitch so it
doesn't really mean i it doesn't really
respect either of the
existing buildings on site
thank you for the christmas council on
the team
when you were looking at this one
we're not really supposed to suggest
uh
um
to the fabrication we can say what we
think is inappropriate or appropriate
and like we i did suggest that and hip
quiz might work better
[Music]
is
yes so the original application was for
a brick-built building with um
[Music]
to the materials
that they are
would be matching the existing property
but didn't want to change
[Music]
stop searching
[Music]
um
[Music]
idea
these properties are
modernized but
is
[Music]
i guess maybe he appears to feel
overbearing on the uh
my proposal would be to go with officers
any other comments
to be honest i can understand what we're
trying to achieve
and that people need working space
okay there's no further comments i'll
ask for a motion
[Music]
page
and that's
[Music]
a
i could ask members to speak clearly
when they uh cast their vote
counselor armitage
for
councillor hartshorne
against
councillor leaguers
councillor jones
absolute power
down to a ramps
and cancel a roth
that's nine votes four and two against
the motions pasture
thank you thank you everybody
if you wish to leave you can
thank you
thank you for coming inside
moving on
we've had a couple of appeals dismissed
so there's one at the crescent play
cross which was a balcony so the main
issue was the impact on the conditions
of neighbours and inspector agreed with
us that the
resultant
and lots of privacy
but the other one was at
free birch eastern
so this is an interesting green green
belt case
and it the main sheet was represented
represents inappropriate development and
there weren't any very special
circumstances
and there's also a cost client refused
that sort of sort of appeals
thank you
[Music]
thank you all very much for attending
this afternoon and see you next time
you